all I've ever wanted is to find my pack
zombies too was the perfect sequel with
great new characters and catchy new
songs but it ended with a huge
cliffhanger does this mean that zombies
3 is happening keep watching to find out
what let's do a quick recap of
everything that happened in zombies 2 we
find out that werewolves used to rule
the land around Seabrook their moonstone
and home were stolen by the settlers
these days life and Seabrook seems
pretty happy zombies are fully
integrated and mostly accepted Addison
is at cheer camp and there are even
zombies on the cheer squad she leads the
newbies to victory
Zed plants an epic invitation to prawn
but it goes awry when the bus full-on
hits him seriously who lets a shrimp
mascot drive a bus they end up in the
Forbidden Forest where Addison sees the
werewolf's we're not alone we're
surrounded by this put Seabrook in a
panic and Addison's mom reinstates all
anti monster laws preventing Zed from
going to the prom the werewolves need to
find the moonstone and recharge their
gems otherwise they won't survive
Wyatt thinks Addison's white hair is a
sign she is the great alpha who will
save them all the Zed runs for school
president against Bucky and Addison has
a chance to become cheer captain she
thinks she might be a werewolf and
joined their pack she and Zed have a
huge fight because he doesn't want her
to be a monster he tries to pass as
human because he thinks that's how
zombies will be accepted everyone unites
and saves the moonstone and the
werewolves recharge their necklaces Zed
an Addison makeup and finally lock lips
at prawn the zombies realized that being
monsters is what makes them special
because I couldn't accept the fact that
I am after the prawn Addison is fast
asleep in her bed we hear what sounds
like an explosion outside her window
something like a blue meteor crashes to
the ground outside of Seabrook Addison
wakes up because her clock radios going
crazy with static and music she looks at
the camera and says weird then her hair
glows
the movie ends on this huge cliffhanger
what does it mean
we know that Addison's hair is
significant in the first movie it just
made her different in zombies too she
thinks it might mean she's a werewolf
but now that her white hair can glow we
have so many questions my hair means
something
zombies too was just released on
February 14th 2020 they are still riding
the wave of the new release so they
haven't officially announced a three
core however there's a huge chance we
will get a zombies three and most fans
agree that the cliffhanger guarantees
that it will happen there's a lot of
other evidence to suggest that we'll get
a third movie too
first up Disney Channel wasn't sure if
zombies 2 would happen so they didn't
end the first movie on a cliffhanger
everything wrapped up neatly
just in case the movie wasn't a success
but it was a huge hit if they weren't
sure about zombies 3 they wouldn't have
ended the movie the way they did ending
on Addison's edge romantic scene would
have been perfect
the zombies franchise also has a couple
of precedents on Disney Channel
sometimes original movies standalone but
their most successful films often turn
into trilogies the Xenon franchise had
three movies Halloweentown had four and
in the last 14 years Disney Channel has
had great success with huge musical
movies
High School Musical is the top Disney
Channel original movie franchise of all
time this musical had two sequels then
descendants happened these movies were
such a huge success they had great
characters and even better music
descendants also became a three movie
franchise the zombies has a lot in
common with those two big musicals there
are edgy musical numbers and awesome
dance scenes and like descendants
zombies has epic like story lines it's
fantasy so it's pretty common that it
requires multiple movies so when will
zombies 3 happen
zombies 2 wasn't even announced until a
full year before it came out we can
expect a confirmation from Disney
Channel in early 2021 filming for both
movies occurred in the spring and early
summer before its release that means the
cast probably won't head back to Toronto
until spring of next year
zombies too came out two years after the
first one so we can expect to see
zombies 3 and 2022 and Disney always
releases its sequels around the same
time of year since the first two were
both released in February
we're probably looking at February of
2022
maybe they'll rename the school after me
one day what cast members will return so
far no one has said they don't want to
come back
most of the principal cast seems open to
a third movie and who can blame them
filming it looked like so much fun and
they're all such close friends
Milo Manheim who plays Zed has confirmed
that he is definitely interested in
telling the next part of the story
Disney will also probably bring back the
same director Paul Hoenn he's done a lot
of great movies for the Disney Channel
and the two other big musical trilogies
kept the same directors Paul will make
sure the third movie feels like the
others the werewolves are now an
important part of Seabrooke they have
expressed interest in returning to
[Applause]
[Music]
we also know that Dom bees 3 will have a
similar theme in message zombies dealt
with accepting others who are different
it was an important message about
prejudice and how it hurts everyone
zombies to continued this theme but took
it to the next level the zed showed that
sometimes we have internalized
prejudices about ourselves this is
common and marginalized communities he
had to learn to accept that what makes
him different makes him special and both
movies had strong themes of
individuality and belonging they teach
us that we should be ourselves and that
we can still belong without conforming
but Addison
still feels like an outsider she wants
to find her pack were sure to see these
themes pop up again in zombies 3 they
think we're monsters we are monsters
so what could some bees three be about
there are a ton of possible plot lines
that we would love to see explored the
first has to do with Addison and her
true identity in the first two movies
Addison is really focused on helping
other people sure she wants to be a
cheerleader and the true captain but the
main point of the first movie was
helping the zombies in the second movie
she wanted to help the werewolves it's
about time we get a movie that is really
all about Addison the cliffhanger makes
us think this is probably the case a
meteor crashing from outer space is a
pretty good indicator that aliens will
be involved was it a meteor or was it a
spaceship it would definitely be on
brand for there to be a new outsider in
seabrooke we will also find out why
Addison's hair is so important the thing
that crashed cause her hair to glow blue
but what does that mean
it has to be more significant than just
identifying her as an alien right does
Addison have special powers that would
be really cool but the movie would need
to explore why these powers just now
popped up it must have something to do
with whatever crashed
they must be testing charges for the
demolition tomorrow let's talk more
about the crash there's the possibility
that it is a spaceship full of aliens if
Addison isn't alien what does that mean
about her parents
Addison could have secretly been adopted
if that's the case her parents have some
serious explaining to do what if they
let her think that she was different for
her entire life without ever coming
clean and then it made her cover up her
hair to look like the perfect daughter
anyway if there are aliens in Seabrook
that it could be Addison's real parents
they might be coming back to find her
will Addison want to be with them or
with the parents who raised her is it
possible that she would choose to leave
Seabrook to learn about who she really
is that would be so sad Addison might
also be a half alien one of her parents
could secretly be from outer space for
some reason they're trying to pass as
human
maybe they got stuck here or maybe
they're on some mission
but what if there is no spaceship maybe
the meteor that fell is something else
entirely
remember Seabrook became prosperous
because of its special energy source
Seabrook power was destroyed them
zombies too the werewolves reclaim the
moonstone so they could charge their
necklaces and save their lives Seabrook
might need a new source of energy it's
possible that without Seabrook power
harnessing the power of the moonstone
Seabrook is struggling the meteor could
be a new source of energy for the town
there's another possibility for to
remember how Eliza had a theory about
zombies evolving she seems they might
not need their Z bands anymore it's true
that Zed was able to control himself
from attacking and he was able to put
the Z band back on but what if the
meteor is actually a way for zombies to
fully integrate they can keep their
zombie strength without endangering the
people around them
Eliza's comment was too significant to
ignore we think zombies evolving could
come into play in the third movie Milo
Manheim has his own theory about zombies
3 and we have to admit it's a good one
Zed and Zoe lived with their dad who
became a foreman overseeing the
demolition of Seabrook power he's a
great dad and Zed and his sister are
both really happy but what happened to
their mom Fanta asked us after the first
movie they have to have a mom right but
she has never mentioned Milo said again
that no one knows what happened to her
is she even alive who knows he said that
sometimes the cast were talked about it
and come up with their own theories he
suggests that finding out what happened
to their mom should be a plot point in
the third movie there's a huge age
difference between Zed and Zoe
so Zed has to remember his mom it's
possible that she went missing
maybe she escaped his Amba town and
Seabrook she might have gone looking for
a cure to help all of the zombies or she
might have just gotten tired of being
segregated
but what if she has something to do with
the crash from outer space maybe Addison
and her abilities are part of a cure for
the zombies it would be cool if Zed's
mom got help from an alien civilization
then zombies wouldn't have to wear their
bands anymore they can have powers
without losing their minds we really
want to know what happened to Zed's mom
and that's a wrap let us know your
zombies three theories in the comment
section when you put it on you'll be
transformed into a werewolf thanks for
watching hit that subscribe button and
give us a big thumbs up see you next
time on the things